I yeah you can sort of like it line up
against the wall this tutorial is you
can do it on your laptop
or you can just sort of like listen and
watch it's up to you so my name is
Cameron Davidson Pilon and again I do
want to thank you for for coming this is
very exciting to me I love this topic
it's been my my kind of like side hobby
for the past nine months so I'm a brain
dump that all on to you so I used to
work at a ecommerce company Shopify I
that was for about five and a half years
I ended back in last December since then
I've been doing food science and food
science projects applying data science
to food and that's been really
interesting I'd love to talk to you
about that afterwards if if you catch me
before we kind of begin I kind of play a
little game just sort of like loosen
everyone up who here thinks they
traveled the farthest to get to to New
York we got one hand two hands okay
we'll start like go ahead you in the
floor oh that's pretty good
Amsterdam that is farther probably who
knows if that's yeah
probably farther yeah definitely yeah
okay
I thought Ottawa was gonna win or or
like that I guess not okay so also well
done you're going to be disappointed by
this so the the tutorials broken up into
two sections the first section is going
to be using our python ipython notebooks
or jupiter notebooks it's going to be
kind of computer work mostly focused on
estimation and sort of the new trends in
estimation I want to show off the second
half though maybe maybe the last third
is gonna be built inference and how to
interpret your your estimates and sort
of modern interpretations of inference
how you know the the sort of deep
thinkers in this field are thinking
about science and statistics and
inference when when Jane contacted me
about doing this tutorial it was
originally supposed to be a statistical
models tutorial and I was like yeah
that's interesting but what I really
want to talk about is
is estimation in general and an
inference and so I pitched that to her
and she was excited and I was just giddy
so so yeah I am very happy to be here
talking about this so OneNote you can
you can get cloned from this repo if you
want to follow on your computer if you
do follow just be mindful of when you're
distracted everyone around you is gonna
be distracted as well if they're looking
at your computer screen so if you're
going to be distracted kind of just like
use your phone or or just be mindful of
the others around you who will also be
distracted and finally please ask me
questions throughout and let's make this
a discussion and kind of a QA thing I
might leave I'm at the end for questions
but I kind of want questions in between
because that's gonna help me gauge where
y'all are at and and a great way to sort
of spur more motivation and spur more
understanding of these topics one more
thing about Bayesian versus frequentist
so a lot of you might know me as a
Bayesian but that's just a hat I wear
sometimes I also put on a frequentist
hat very often because both methods are
really useful if I were to sort of sort
of like prioritize things I would say
try a Bayesian approach at first if that
doesn't work do a frequentist but
frequentists our use of methods are
still really useful and what they should
be discussed and they're there they're
really fun to do so this talk is can be
more about the frequentist ideas but
you're gonna know something notice like
a lot of Bayesian flavor and in the
inference and the estimation approaches
ok great so I'm gonna assume you've done
this if not just find me on github and
you can find this repo and then go ahead
and get clone it if you've already done
that do a git pull because I've maybe
updated something since the last time
you cloned it but let's let's begin
so we'll start if you ordered the repo
we'll start we'll open up the Jupiter
notebooks using your command line if
you're having problems just like maybe
ask the person next next to you you also
would have to pip install the
requirements file if you haven't done
that already most of it's part of the
normal stack that we're using the repu
one exception called Auto grad which are
get into later but try doing that if you
haven't done already okay so we're gonna
go to the tutorial notebooks not the
full notebooks those are for reference
later
so tutorial notebooks there's just some
pieces missing that we're going to fill
in as we go and we're gonna start in
part one let me just make sure rate and
the people in the back can you read that
okay that's good
great so we're gonna fit some data to a
parametric model and a parametric model
it's it's sort of fully specified it has
unknown parameters that we want to fit
the the data to I mean it's it's we're
just curve fitting essentially using
like a something a bit more advanced
than linear regression but that's what a
parametric model is we want to create
the log-likelihood and then we're going
to optimize over that so the
log-likelihood contains all the
information came contains like the
parametric model contains the data and
we want to maximize that function we'll
create some fake data first members
shift-enter is how you can execute these
cells so shift-enter we can see this is
our our data so it's it's that's the
data turning process doesn't really
matter how I got this data but it looks
like this we want to fit some parametric
model to this so the first four for
positive data and this is strictly
positive data I really good approach is
the Weibull distribution we're gonna
like I'm not gonna make you type this
out because it's complicated and very
error-prone but it looks like this
there's two parameters lambda and Rho
lambdas like the scale it kind of
defines like the units of your data and
Rho is this kind of flexible parameter
that defines the shape but that's the
this is the PDF in Python code the log
PDF is actually what we need for the
log-likelihood and again I'm not gonna
make you type this up because it's super
error-prone the last step is this log
likelihood it just takes log PDF of the
params and P and we just sum it all up
that's that's the log-likelihood cool
any questions you should have had to
type anything yet so
so this is easy to execute this great
and the first kind of like a core
function we're going to use today is
sci-fi optimize minimize I use this all
the time it's really really useful it's
great not even refer for both continuous
and discrete problems for for parametric
and savvy parametric problems it's as
easy as entering in log-likelihood and
some initial guess if you want method
work on touch method today by default
minimized will try to minimize the first
argument of the function which in our
case is params which we want to minimize
or we want to sort of like optimize over
that but you pass in sort of residual or
residual extra arguments in this args
function okay so this is where we start
typing let's type saw or let's enter in
some initial guesses for these
parameters so we have two parameters the
lambda and the Rho so it should give it
a two parameter all right or two vectors
or two length array Rho and lambda are
both strictly positive so it makes no
sense to put 0 and 0 that's not really
gonna do anything useful so I put 1 and
1 those are pretty good defaults and
okay yeah okay I think this is just
gonna work cool we got man as that
expected one moment yes ok so we got an
an what happened well there's a much
like warnings here and stuff the problem
is is that this is minimizing something
but we want to maximize the log plug
likelihood so really what we should have
done is put a negative sign in front of
what we just did or we had up there so
it should be like negative N P dot some
I
this is sounds silly but like this is
one of the most common mistakes that
people make log PDF that they forget
that you want to minimize or maximize
log likelihoods you want to minimize the
negative log likelihood
and I should fix things if you try again
[Music]
where am i that did not work weird that
oh right sorry
yeah there's one more thing we have to
do okay so this is the final piece to
this minimize thing like I said Rho and
lambda are strictly positive so we need
to tell minimize that they're strictly
positive that's the thing we're missing
because minimize thinks it's like it's
the entire reals so it's gonna say that
let me try a negative one and you're
taking if you go back to that log PDF
you know you're taking them you know the
log of negative one it makes no sense so
we're gonna put in this the final
argument bounds equals and then how it
works is it takes a list of bounds so
because we have a bound of 0 and a
unbounded right-hand side we just put
like 0 none and that's for both
parameters on 0 and subtract it cool and
it still didn't work
we're getting there this is literally
what you do when you can reuse minimize
it's like I've had to do this so many
times
ok one more thing technically 0 doesn't
work either because what the algorithm
is gonna do now you go at the often
ization algorithm it's gonna try 0
because it's a boundary condition to see
like well maybe the boundary is the is a
minimum it's gonna fail because log of 0
is still man so we're putting these very
small constants wonderful good okay so
these are our our unknown values that
we've are there they're now known values
that we've fitted so these values
maximize the likelihood the log
likelihood which tells us these are like
the best values for this parametric
model oh yeah and this oh yeah so the
takeaway is minimize it's very flexible
it can do like you know you can put them
bounds you can put in args you can
change the the optimization algorithm
you can kind of like and this is
actually very very useful you can give
it good initial guesses because it's
actually quite like most problem
are not going to be convex and really
lovely [ __ ] problems so the right
initial values is gonna give you a
better solution so minimize is very very
general and it's like a workhorse that
that we can use often over and over
again it's good for small to mid-size
problems as you get into like higher
higher dimensions you might want to
switch to and in that case it's hard to
reason about the convexity of this bowl
or this this likelihood so you might
want to use like a gradient descent
algorithm and maybe in that case you
don't really care about finding the
actual global minimum so a great descent
would work pretty well for now for our
tutorial we're gonna stick with only
small to mid-size problems anyways so
we'll stick with this good question is
like what is mid mean and I don't know
it could be 100 it could be 12 it kind
of depends on on how much data you have
depends on your domain it depends on
like how complicated your model is but
we'll stick with that okay a few
problems though we were stuck using only
parametric models that are relatively
easy to implement they have like a
closed-form solution there they're like
relatively easy to write down in code
and we're still using minimization
routines that don't use any gradient
information so that likelihood it's
think of the thing as a bull our open
base optimization algorithm is just
picking a point kind of looking locally
as to what's less than where I am and
going that direction it's more
complicated than that but it's not
really using gradient information it's
just kind of hill climbing down so what
we're gonna do better for that let's
move on to part two
I have to go here so if you know me I
really like survival analysis so
remember some survival analysis I like
it because it uses the the main tool of
today three times at least three times
so we're going to use it survival
analysis it's not that complicated just
if it is the censoring problem so if I
have data that looks like this data so
it's so say like I had a bunch of births
at time zero and then at time ten I take
a snapshot of who's still around or how
long did those those people live for
those subjects live for three of them
the in the blue lines they continued on
they they were they exist at that time
ten everyone else died before time ten
so the naive thing to do is just take
the mean of all this data that's gonna
give you an under estimate because of
these blue lines the other naive thing
to do is to ignore those blue lines
that's silly because obviously obviously
there's information there because in
reality you know it might look like this
you can't really tell but there it died
this person died like shortly after so
this is the true data we have to sort of
account for that censorship problem
where we only have data from at time 10
up to time 10 so to do that we're gonna
do a bit of probability theory a bit of
math so mathematically we know that if T
capital T is this like random kind of
life time we can define the survival
function as 1 minus its CDF so we had
this case of no censoring I'll bring it
up in the case there's no censoring
where we just sum over all the observed
data however if we have censoring say
like we can put a population to two we
have the observed and a censored the
observed is the exact same it's like the
log of what we observed as their exact
death for the censored people though all
we know is that the death happened in
the future we have like T capital T is
greater than 10 I don't know when
I know this is greater than 10 so we
have this additional term of log S or
the survival function s you can do the
trick of dividing by 1 and multiplying
by 1 which is like a fancy way to say
like divided by s of T and multiplied by
s of T which is still like multiplying
by 1 we can do that we can take some
some you know logarithmic properties
this is just here for the derivation if
you want to go through it but at the end
we get these these useful functions that
are kind of the heart of survival
analysis we have this negative log s of
T which is shows up here we define that
as the cumulative hazard copper or the
noted capital H of T so we stick that
cumulative hazard here and then you can
do this a bit more math and figure out
that this PDF over s that's equal to we
develop that small H of T because it's
exactly equal to the derivative of the
cumulative hazard ignoring all that what
you end up with is this much prettier
interesting kind of log likelihood
that's the log of H of T this hazard
function only at the observed times
minus the sum over all the cumulative
hazards so this is what rush you're
going to work with rather than thinking
about PDFs and CD f's and and Strabo
functions there's a reason why we go
this route and it'll be more clear later
on but there's actually there's also
like a interpretation to what the hazard
means when your hazard spikes it means
you're more likely to to perish or the
end of these subjects more likely to
perish the cumulative hazard is just the
the integral of the hazard so you start
thinking about hazards instead of
thinking about like probability
distributions you think about hazards
like when our subjects susceptible to
dying for a human there's a high risk
early on before year 1 and then it sort
of sinks down kind of rises again during
like the teenage years sinks back down
and then around like 50 hours to
gradually go up so that's like the
hazard profile of humans
we'll see some more examples and to
become like more interesting or more and
more clear so now we're gonna work in
hazard space instead of probability
space think about hazards from now on
okay so one thing to take away too is
that we're using the log likelihood
function to add information about our
system so again I go back up here we're
adding that there were centered cases
and this is kind of like a common theme
throughout today's talk that we use the
logs likelihood or the likelihood to add
information about our data it's a very
useful idea and we'll take advantage of
the advantage of it a few times ok on to
clicking again
ok so we're the cumulative hazard for
the Weeble is super simple it's just
this T divided by lambda to the power of
Rho much easier than that that log PDF
we had before the hazard if you just do
some calculus is equal to this is just
the derivative of the cumulative hazard
with respect to T so it's just equal to
this the log hazard I just like the log
of the hazard of course and then the log
likelihood is just written here the same
way as we have it up here there's this
new parameter or ya argument he is like
a vector of boolean's one if that
subject was observed to die and zero if
they were censored so zero if they died
in the future and I don't see okay so we
should get the same thing we had the
same bounds the same initial argument
it's the same data but I've added a few
a few censured cases just randomly
okay thanks failed again that's okay
it's supposed to in this case okay
first debugging oh and you get the
sometimes you get a negative in fear
again that's because we forgot to put
this negative sign in its stress like I
get so many emails by people saying like
oh why isn't this converging and they
forgot the negative signs so I just want
to stress that
okay so we're created a new function
called the negative log likelihood which
is a better name then then we had before
so if you're following we're gonna put
the negative blog fluffy hood into here
note the args has T and E now because
both those parameters are being passed
in and this should just work great okay
so these are our estimates for Rho and
lambda and again I stress it's it's it's
cool because we actually had partial
information about these subjects in the
future we didn't see them die but we can
still do inference on them if you wanted
to you could like see the influence of
those of those censored cases like here
I'm saying everyone is observed so this
is like 10.43 0.42 ones like like so
yeah like this parameter the lambda
parameter changed quite a bit
just based because we didn't take into
account those censored cases but I want
to keep them there
oops great and we can also like plot the
estimated survival function if we wanted
because the relationship between the
cumulative hazard and Serano function
it's just e to the negative cumulative
hazard as the survival function we can
plot the survival function which is
great that's typically what the business
wants to see they want to see survival
functions that's also what you're going
to use a lot in your business problems
you want to know like what's the
probability that the individual survives
until time X so next we're going to move
on to my favorite part of this whole
track is automatic differentiation so
let's open up part three
part three so the the tagline here and I
love this tagline is how to
differentiate an algorithm so you might
from from you know second year first
year calculus or even like third your
calculus know how to differentiate a
one-dimensional function or
n-dimensional function automatic
differentiation is how to differentiate
an algorithm I can't imagine what math
notation I might look like to
differentiate an algorithm but you can
do it which blows me away so you have
tools like like senpai wolfram
mathematica that can differentiate
symbolically so x squared differentiated
is 2x and we're comfortable with that
but how do we differentiate something
like this so it's an it's it's an
algorithm it has its for loop it has
this assignment operator it's kind of
complicated if you were to write it out
in math it would look like this this
like very nested sine function and if
you plot it it's like it's a legit
function it's an American function it
might be completely contrived but like
it does give you a numerical output so
how do you differentiate this like
what's the derivative of this say like 0
or 0.5 you could approximate it using a
numerical method by like taking a step
forward taking the difference and then
dividing by that difference that's like
the kind of classical Newton way to
approximate a gradient but that's
expensive
as you enter higher dimensions that
becomes infeasible because you're having
to do this little like step trick for
every single dimension and that becomes
very slow it's also imprecise especially
around like a special round like high
very steep areas it becomes imprecise so
introducing this tool called Auto grad
it's Auto grab and an automatic
differentiation has been around to about
20 years but it's only recently become
useful because neural nets are becoming
more more complicated and that's kind of
where its motivation came from is to
like differentiate these complicated
neural nets but we can take advantage of
it - for these simpler models and it
totally clears up and cleans up lots
lots of code it makes your code more
testable it's less error-prone it'sit's
really really nice
so autograph will not compute
symbolic derivatives like 2x vs x
squared it will compute point wise exact
point wise derivatives so for example I
have this function rewritten importantly
I have to use Auto grads numpy that's
just like a little thing we have to do
it doesn't make it a huge difference but
it's exact same you just treat NP as the
exact same as like NP dot sine and we
can do something like this so this
negative 0.26 is the derivative of this
function at 1 so back up here so that is
negative
0.26 weight sorry here which is crazy
it's like it differentiated this
algorithm which is this written note and
if this isn't complicated enough for you
like let me add in some more things if Y
is greater than 0 let's say Y is equal
to 1 or something plus X I don't care
squared like x + p dot exp why it
doesn't like it you can do anything I'm
going to make sure this works yeah sure
great cool so again you can do
randomness sure it's going to be fine so
we're in a random derivative but that's
fine
are you doubting that it's gonna do this
100 obviously and I guess okay you can
go back up here and put in zero and I
would work out I guess oh look at this
oh okay great so a great question I love
this question this is such a good
question so what happens at these these
boundary points like a simpler case of
non differentiability is the absolute
value I would say two things I would say
one it doesn't matter and I would say
like for often like you don't need it at
zero or at these differentiable or non
differentiable points so if you think
about a optimization algorithm the
chances of it having to evaluate some
gradient at zero is like close to
vanishing and of all like the floating
point numbers it's gonna happen
eventually but that's like a minor edge
case it seems like a minor noise you
could also like program in what you
wanted to do at zero to make it like
smoother or something I mean we're not
working with what is it vice stresses
not a differentiable function or
whatever so this this stuff is okay it's
just gonna like it's gonna choose the
code path that it needs to go down to
get a derivative at that point so yeah
your math professor might have said you
can't differentiate absolute value but
you can differentiate algorithms yes
yeah yeah yeah totally yeah so what it's
doing it's applying the chain rule the
product rule over and over again
recursively so let's take the derivative
of sine x squared using auto-da-fé at
zero
it's important like it's point y so I'm
saying at zero so first it's going to
inspect its code and it's gonna start to
unpack itself so it's going to first
look at okay let's look at the most
inner function which is x squared what's
the derivative of x squared it has a
look up so it knows how to differentiate
x squared or X at the end it has a look
up for sine X so it's gonna go okay this
is this functions called x squared the
look up is 2x so I'm going to put in two
times my point zero so then I get zero
and then it goes to the next outer
function which is sine X it can go we're
gonna go to look up sine X derivative is
negative coast or coast and then it's
going to put in zero for that
they both have a look up I guess but I
think that's where the similarities end
so sin pi is going to return the the the
entire function to you this is going to
compute it on the fly
yeah maybe that thing that there's like
a tree in the background yeah oh yeah I
think I forgot to multiply by yeah I'll
take care of that yeah I think my
derivative was wrong when I said it
aloud but yeah it takes care of that all
that stuff so so like simp I would not
be able to be able to answer this but
auto difficut but it takes advantage of
these like very very simple derivative
operations like chain rule and probably
rule and things like that
other questions and it's exact - which
is so crazy to me like it's not an
approximation this is exact and you can
show it like you know you can try
something so the student lambda thanks
grad F at 1 it should be 2 right yeah so
it's exact yeah which is pretty sweet
yes yeah
that's being inputted I dislike some
Python logic to check if it's a numpy
array or a scalar do you want me to try
something
sure yeah but it's also like because the
primitives are still numpy functions
behind the hood if you know if I give if
my sort of tree my autograph tree has 2x
in it X can be a scalar or a numpy array
and it still gonna like nope I still
going to compute those things correctly
just to sort of like with them like this
should return oh yeah have to use a
different function for that but we'll
get we'll get into element wise so grad
is useful for or maybe I'll mmm I'll
show you one more trick I would show one
more thing forbus look here so say a two
parameter
now forget it don't do it we'll get into
vector base things in a second so you
can look it up how this this stuff works
if you think about it like tensorflow is
just a auto-da-fé library like pi torte
is just an auto-da-fé library they're
really really good at it and they offer
like GPU support and a bunch of other
tools and in like like neural network
components but that's kind of what like
the core is you have this very
complicated algorithm that who knows how
to take the derivative of like a CNN or
a like recursive neural net eyelid if
it's like a no problem
look I can I can do that it's the point
why is you just tell me what to evaluate
and I'll do it so you can also just
moving on you can also string together
even though I just point wise you can
sort of string things together and still
plot things oh yeah I've just modified
this quite a bit
let me just not do this anymore so it's
a bit prettier
so that's the derivative of this this
sine function that we had before and it
you know it looks like it should it's
the derivative okay so how are we gonna
use this in our optimization routines
I'm gonna pick up ASIS a little bit
sorry we're going to use this in the
optimizer to compute gradients that the
optimizer can use and we can compute
Hessians which I'll get to which it's
really important so same data same log
likelihoods we can take the gradient of
the log or the negative log likelihood
just using grad negative log likelihood
cool so because the negative log
likelihood has two parameters this
lambda row we return we return two
derivatives to its gradient so we have
two outputs one for the gradient of
lambda one for the gradient of row this
is evaluate at 1 1 and we stick it in
using this Jack Jacobian also called a
Jacobean argument so jack equals this
and we put the result and we get the
same thing it's different data so we get
slightly different answers but yeah we
can also actually make this a bit more
efficient we can use this value and grad
which returns the value of the function
and the gradient of that function in one
call so how this works is we set Jack to
equal true as you can see here and we
put in just negative log likelihood here
this value in grad was kind of designed
for minimize so this just makes things
more efficient because I could compute
if you think about the gradient
calculation and the actual function
calculation they share a lot of shared
symbols like there's a sign X in some
places and assign X in other places this
just computes the entire tree it's makes
both the gradient and the actual
function calculation faster and we get
the same results great cool moving on to
part four
oops well that's not my idea
okay so let's start generalizing our
models so previously we had this weeble
distribution why did we choose Weeble
who knows just because let's so we're
going to shift our data a little bit to
the right just kind of like a total
constant shifted to the right let's
create this new parameter called mu
which is actually like it tries to model
our shifted data now and if you think
about the log hazard okay so what was
the hazard the hazard was the derivative
of the human through the human of hazard
but a derivative like let's not compute
that anymore like why are we computing
derivatives by hand let's use auto grand
so we're gonna do the log hazard is just
the log tonight do this later on yeah I
did okay so the log hazard has this is
complicated I don't really know what it
is I have this new Mew thing it could be
mu squared it could be whatever but
we're gonna use auto grad to do that
computation exactly for us so note that
the derivative is respect to T with the
hazard so that's these are numb equal 1
or like the second position so we put in
1 here so we're saying take the
derivative with respect to the second
parameter T so this is our hazard the
log hazard just becomes NP log of the
hazard so we get the gradient with
respect to the three parameters in the
log hazard so in summary like don't do
derivatives anymore don't calculate
derivatives by hand unless you need like
performance or speed and you're not
gonna make a mistake just rely on or
lean hard on auto grad to do the
derivatives for you so this is the same
code as previously negative log
likelihood we throw it into our
optimizer and notice - we have this new
parameter mu so I give it the initial
starting point of zero because you could
kind of be anywhere it's like a shift
it's like a location parameter I also
have to be careful though with adding it
to my bounds said this kind of like
bounds logic print the results and we
kind of get what we expected when we
added four to our data we've now
subtracted four in this mute parameter
everything kind of worked out great and
if you're good at like now parameter
accounting the idea of like how many
parameters does the model require how do
I deal with like arbitrary X naught and
arbitrary bounds you can kind of just
create whatever parameters you want or
whoever whatever parametric models you
want like I could go back up here and
add in more parameters if I wanted
because you know make my data it slight
subtleties that I want to model I want
to add in a few more like hazard
functions and I can combine it all and
get this new function and if I just you
know change a few things here everything
just works this also can be extended to
regression models so I have say lambda X
this is with no more location new stuff
I had this lambda X and say lambda X as
a function of two covariates that might
maybe are relevant to my to my problem
so I'm just going to create some
regression data here the this all is
like the exact same code is above I just
have this additional X thing and then in
my cumulative hazard I just have to like
kind of do an numpy dot product that's
about it great create this new lambda
and then I this is identical tobe head
above so I have how many parameters or
how many unknowns I have a row
I have beta 1 beta 2 so I just need you
know three initial arguments some bounds
my betas can be we just can be both
negative into positive infinity so I
have nuns here but this should oh yeah
so we have to fill this in what should
go here so params if you think about it
so lambda log lambda Co X that's just
the first two params and then the row is
the last one like that some kind of
doing unpacking
and we get you know the results back so
so this can be extended very easily to
regression models so you might be asking
like it has a good statistician or data
scientist would like what about my
variances we have like that we've only
been doing point estimates I want to
talk about like variances I want to know
how uncertain I am and that's that's
great that's like the kind of Bayesian
attitude I like to hear so we're gonna
move on to part five and discuss that so
under some some conditions that I won't
get into for brevity's sake but you can
look them up what school is it okay you
think about your your MLE problem your
maximum likelihood problem which we'll
be doing there's the you know maybe this
bowl that you're trying to minimize and
find the bottom what school is the
second derivative at that point at that
minimum that's called the Hessian and
that tells you information about the the
variance of you're uncertain of your
parameters your known parameters at
least like once you take the inverse of
that and the diagonal so you have this H
which is the Hessian evaluated the
second derivative evaluated at the
minimum point of your bull you take the
inverse of that matrix and take the
diagonals and those are the variances of
your your parameters that you just fit
and you might be thinking okay wait why
do I variances on my parameters well you
just did like a statistical problem
there should be variances somewhere if I
had like two data points there will be a
high variance and those parameters so we
want to be able to reflect that we won't
be able to say like yeah there's still
uncertainty in this system and this is
how you can do that you just take the
Hessian and then you invert it and they
they're like no but again like the
second derivative let's not do this by
hand let's use auto grad so there's this
function called Hessian or first Peter
and some data and we do the fit and the
fits fine did I forget something yeah
okay great that's fine it's I think we
threw the same model yeah it's just a
weeble model so
it's as we expected great so here we're
gonna do the Hesse and this Hessian
function of the negative log of the
likelihood evaluated at that minimum so
there's that bowl here's the minimum we
want the second derivative at that
minimum it's a matrix it's like the
second derivative with respect to all
arguments so it's a matrix it's a
two-by-two system so we should have a so
it's a two parameter system which we
should have a two-by-two matrix which we
do great so using that equation above we
just take the inverse and this is a bit
too small sorry folks we take the
inverse and then tie a diagonal and we
get variances on these estimates that's
like really really easy and cheap to get
variance parameters on this model taking
the square root gives us the standard
deviation or the standard error and
finally we have this beautiful very very
easily done kind of summary table so we
have our estimates plus our plus our
uncertainty to all those estimates to
prove it like you can go back up and
change the sample sizes so let's make
that 100 and we should see a like
increase in the and the the variances as
expected so that's that's again just
leaning on some principles of maximum
likelihood estimation that the Hessian
contains variance information and then
again leaning hard on our grad to do
that Hessian calculation for us I
remember I was trying to do this this is
pre auto grad I was trying to calculate
the Hessian for the log normal model for
a survival model and it sucked it was
like awful it took me forever to do and
it was this big long I put it in and
Wolfram Alpha and it was this huge
massive long thing like each each
element of that matrix was this big
massive long thing and it was air prone
as I was typing it in it just it was
such a hassle and that was like the
simple log normal model which has like
again two parameters this just did it no
problem
like I could I could change my log
normal model to anything more
complicated and this is just going to do
it the exact same way
so this was quick but I want to show you
the next part which i think is really
important we also want to talk about the
business right you're not going to go to
your CFO or your PM or your fellow
researcher and say like yeah
Rho was less than 0.53 like wait wait
but what's what's Rho mean often there's
a business reason for doing this and
there's a business function that
connects your parametric model to some
outcome so we'll do that next
in part 6 yeah so I mean here here's a
story you know the CFO wants know what's
a variation in churn and you tell them
lambdas been increasing but Rho is
staying the same and then the CFO says
you know what banana value is increasing
what he's talking about so what we want
is a connection to our business problem
keep in mind we've only been working
with the cumulative hazard we haven't we
talked about the survival function in a
while but let's say we won't actually
present survive a function to our to our
CFO or our stake holder or the the
medical professional so we want to know
what's this the confidence interval the
CI for the survival function at these
best values at like the maximum
likelihood estimates okay so there's
this great thing called the Delta method
think of it as if this is more
appropriate and linear linear a lot
linearizing the problem to to create
like a simpler simpler model but
essentially the variance of some F F is
like your business problem in our case F
is equal to s the survival function it's
equal to the gradient of f at the
parameters times the variance variance
matrix that we just calculated times the
gradient again so we know what the
variance of the parameters is that's the
inverse of the Hessian do we need to
compute the gradient of F by hand
no let's again use auto grad
F could be something very very
complicated which we'll see in the next
part but for now F is just going to be
the survival function so going through
we've seen all this this is the same old
same old same weebo model two parameter
we will model we execute great so we
have this new function called the
survival function and this takes in
parameters takes in a time and we know
the relationship between the survival
function and the cume hazard is just
negative exp negative okay so this next
part so the what's the variance at t if
we use or sorry here gradient of s FF
this is just great in a suburban
function as we've kind of seen and
getting used to cool so that should work
if we execute yep so the gradient of the
strawman function at these parameters
these optimized parameters so the
variance at T is that that matrix
multiplication above so it was grad of F
or survival function sorry I already
have this grad of SS times the estimates
at t dot products or does it dot product
the variance matrix which I did not run
I don't think
variance matrix at or multiplied by the
gradient of SF again at T and is there
yeah that's it so if you think about it
this is 2x2 this is like to buy one as
we saw this is 1 by 2 or 2 by 1 and so
we should get a scalar at the end and we
do cool so this is the variance of the
struggle function at time 5 and from
that from the variance we can construct
standard errors and then confidence
intervals which we'll do next
cool
so this function was just this equation
up here and again I don't have to
compute the gradient of struggle
function oughta Gregg did that for me
ya know so the diagonals for the
variance of the point estimates what I
need is the that's not so clear this is
a matrix of the it's the covariance
matrix yeah yeah yeah so does it
collapse the covariance matrix but yeah
so that's that's how to get the variance
of a function a business function the
next if we move on to part seven this
will be a much more applicable example I
believe okay so let's look at like a
lifetime value example if you're not
familiar with SAS businesses like
subscription businesses they have this
very predictable churn cycle so it's
because the SAS businesses work by we
charge them monthly or the company
charges that monthly at the end of the
month at the end of like a 30 day cycle
is a big drop-off in customers and then
it's pretty flat there's some churn but
then big drop-off at day 60 and so on so
very predictable but you might not know
you know how what's the what's the rate
of churn in those kind of predictable
intervals one way to model this
is like a piecewise hazard so you might
have low turn initially before towels
zero and then between tau 0 and tau 1
there's a high churn and then back down
to low churn highchair and so it's this
piecewise model of hazard so that's
that's kind of how like a SAS business
my model its churn so there should be if
this doesn't work let me know but there
should be a churn data set in that repo
that we can just copy I think I have a
not yet you can plot it if you want I
don't think there's any censorship but
there's a matter for though there is
censorship yeah so the break points
that's for us to decide I'm going to
decide that it's on day 28 when the
regime changes when the customer kind of
mentality changes and they're about to
be charged they might turn so on day 28
between day 20 and day 33 that's that
spike and then between day 33 and day 58
it's kind of low again and then spike
low again and so on so it's up to us to
define this cumulative hazard function
again it has a the same signature params
and times in this case though this is
like some serious numpy black magic in
order to get this we can chat after but
just assume this is going to give you
the cumulative hazard of the piecewise
constant model stop reading it everyone
it's gonna hurt so again we have hazard
is just you know the element-wise grad
of the cumulative hazard cool it's cool
it just I just want to point this out
like I write this once and then
everything just works like I don't care
what the hazard is I don't care about
log hazard or log likelihood it's just
it just works okay so we get the
optimization I think we had what nine
parameters that we estimated that was
pretty fast so these are the the lambdas
the hazard rates in each of these like
period these time periods and we can
plot that and this is a yeah so this is
what the COS survival curve of a SAS
company might look like I see some like
nodding heads like oh yeah it's familiar
but that's that's what happens happening
these kind of big jumps
are like we're about to charge them and
the customers like oh no like I'm
bouncing from your service and it kind
of flattens out because you you sort of
lose the week customers and this kind of
churn period and you get like better and
better customers over time that's kind
of what it looks like but let's say
let's say like this is our business
problem let's say we on or on day 30 we
charge users $10 that's like the first
monthly cost and then on every 30 days
after that we charge 20 it can be more
complicated but we want to know what's
what's the LTV of a customer when what
are the see is the compas intervals of
that that customer that's like a
non-obvious problem I think if it's not
obvious you can make this complicated or
this function more complicated so I
think I have time yeah okay so let's do
we're do it this way LTV is zero again
this is we're going to Ferengi eight
this which is kind of crazy but just
write it like you wouldn't normally
write a numpy function so to be equals
zero this is going to work
LT V plus equals so it's ten dollars for
the first month times the survival
function which I don't I do write that
after one look
oh cool okay so it's $10 times the
probability of surviving at time 30 so
it's survival function which is defined
up here just the negative cumulative
hazard times are at at time params time
30 30 days and then for you know like
day and
day in range or sorry list
let's do 60 90 120 LT V plus equals $20
right yep
times survival Graham's day so you might
you might have a discount coupon code or
something that you want to include in
this business logic or you might want to
include you know cohort details in here
or something kind of whatever you want
like this is like this is going to
connect your mathematical parametric
model to what the CFO or the the PM
wants to see on their desk and I think
this is gonna work you lips oh yeah who
knew that it you guys know that that's
so interesting I didn't know that I I
think I did oh this was an actual Python
thing but I didn't it would print out
like that okay LTV that's great so in
this case the the best estimate of the
LTV because we already fit the model the
best estimate of the LTV at 120 days is
51 cool $51 but more importantly is the
CI like if we if we have a massive
variance in that and that LTV boob might
want to change our strategy or even just
even more probably appropriately
represent in some vis that uncertainty
okay so the variance of the LTV or the
sort of the yeah the parents are the LCB
that's an equal to the
rad of LTV 120 evaluated at estimates
perhaps I think or my way off I think
I'm office actually yeah my off sorry
the variance involves that complicated
matrix stuff so it's the it's a delta
method again so it's the the grad of the
LTV or a book business function times
the variance covariance matrix times the
function again to grab the function
again if I'm typing too fast you're not
keeping up I'm sorry just let me know
cool so what do we get one point six and
take a square root that's a standard
error and we can compute the compas
intervals by just looking at like say
the 95th approximation or whatever this
is I forget but this is our confidence
interval for the 120-day ltb model just
trying one more thing let's go back up
here let's just truncate the data by a
lot let's do let's just remove up 200
points and was an error
oh there's too many parameters and not
enough data yeah let's do 200 great
so we have we have a wider CI as
expected so when's this talk it's still
245 right okay okay I will let you all
look at this on your on your own time
it's interesting it's kind of that's a
bit of a Bayesian pooling model to this
model I'll quickly jump in or quickly
explain it I'll just say let's say I
want I assume this is probably correct
that the in between periods the rate of
the in between periods are correlated
and the above model we just let them be
whatever they want it to be the best
like just fit this curve fit but let's
assume that we think that those the
churn rate and the in between periods is
correlated also the churn rate in the
high turan periods is is correlated as
well so we can add some like additional
information to our model and so you can
run through this and kind of explore
what happens if I do that so again the
the story behind this is we use our
likelihood to add more information some
prior information about our our system
and we can do like a via but we get
better statistical efficiency by doing
that okay but yeah you can all look at
that okay so we move on to part eight
and this is this is a quick one it's
it's just the idea of optimizing over an
unbounded space which is typically more
efficient and more robust your
estimations more robust so in all of our
previous models we had the bound the
boundary condition of parameter must be
positive so we had that 0 comma none and
all of our optimizations I mentioned
this because this is another problem
that I see a lot people run into instead
of optimizing and having that bound we
can take the log of that parameter which
turns it into like a number that can be
from negative infinity to infinity
and we optimize over that the log of the
parameter I'll show an example a second
but the same thing applies to if we have
a parameter that sort of fits between
zero
one we can express it in in real space
in like between negative and and imp and
then take the the X bit function and
which converts it back to be between 0 &
1
so the important thing is that there's a
1:1 correspondence between values in the
real line and 0 1 1 through this
function so for example we have this
turn problem again and instead of
instead of putting the params and the
assumed the params are gonna be positive
let's assume it's the log of the params
so we take the log of lambda which is
going to be between which could be any
number and then inside our model we just
exponentiate them to make sure it's
still positive and we still have like
meaningful cumulative hazards and so if
we do that oh what goes where oh yeah
yeah here so notice to we have this
again no more bounce because we're not
assuming that the premise are positive
anymore we're just saying like pick
anything our model is going to kind of
like convert it back to positive and
then here if we want to get recover the
original parameters we just do XP XP of
the log of the estimates go up and if
you go back to the previous part you'll
see that that's the exact same thing so
this is just a way to get around
complicated bounds
you just model it as a real number and
then use some converting function a
one-to-one function to go back into the
space that you actually want it's just
more efficient to do it that way you can
take advantage of more complicated
algorithms optimization algorithms so
the funny thing is like this is exactly
what life lines does like this this
entire tutorial up till now that's what
life lines is really doing under the
hood it's just using autograph a lot to
do all these calculations it has classes
where as we've been using functions and
life lines is like I said good at
parameter accounting the idea of like ok
how many
premises this model have that's why I
have to like specify my optimization
signature great so that was the extent
of the computer tutorial we're gonna
move on to the interpretation the the
modern trends in inference I guess in
summary of what we just learned
like autograph is crazy and awesome and
use it to your advantage
computing derivatives by hand is
old-school it'll be like you know like
sorting was in 1940 like you know you
you learned it and the end you have to
do it by hand but then algorithms came
along it just made it way way better
1940 was the wrong year but you get the
idea where am i okay so we did that so
let's talk about interpreting what we
just did we talked a little bit like we
saw some CIS we didn't see P values but
P values is just the point estimate
divided by the variance we didn't look
at that but that's also very common in
especially like software output of
models you'll see a p-value you'll see
the CIS
let's talk about what those things mean
and when they're they're not good and
when they're better alternatives okay so
like I said you might get output after
after running or these models I'm
actually gonna switch this will be
easier it's gonna change my arrangement
so we can see what you see
excellent okay so I mean I'm talking
about the p-value first the p-value is
something to do with a null hypothesis I
don't want to get into like what the
p-value really means the most important
thing is that it's often misused there
are cases a preface this before I get
into more there are cases where P values
make a lot of sense and you want to be
using p-values I'm thinking like like
reliability engineering when you have
the same experiment constantly you're
constantly pulling things off the line
and checking things that's what you do
have this kind of frequentist paradigm
working really really well but if you
didn't one-off experiment on in
psychology or or in the lab p-values
make less sense and they're often often
misused as we've seen with the sort of
crisis going on now so that's something
something to do with a null hypothesis
but what is the null hypothesis anyways
Gelman argues I Andrew Gelman who's a
famous Bayesian at Columbia he argues
that the null hypothesis is never true
which I really like
the null hypothesis is say like beta
equals zero but like you really don't
think ever that beta is exactly zero
right like that just doesn't make any
sense it's all mostly you know it's
completely unlikely for beta to equal
exactly zero so he argues the null
hypothesis is always false it's kind of
a tongue-in-cheek
thing but it's kind of true it's like
we're the fundamental part of null
hypothesis testing is kind of on shaky
ground already one thing to keep in mind
too when you get these these outputs
from your software is that tiny p-values
like you know 0.001 whatever when you
have lots lots of data they're probably
due to a violation in the assumptions
and not any real effect so recall what
the assumptions are in any kind of
statistical model that uses p-values
it's the assumptions the the null model
you're really testing is the assumptions
Plus H naught so assumptions in this
case is like do you have a linear model
a linear model do you need that
interaction term or do you not need that
interaction term
these kind of assumptions that you're
making with your model so a tiny p-value
might mean oh you just violated a
linearity assumption and your p-value is
very very small not because you got rid
of the null hypothesis but because you
just violated something it's more
obvious with big data because the models
better able to like see that assumption
being violated so there's things you
should worry about instead of p-values
like a poorly conceived research
question or poor data stewardship each
one of these like I've experienced and I
know it's a problem sloppy research
brought procedures poor management
measurement that happens all the time
avoidable errors and then the analysis
just the wrong model altogether
the source is here but yeah did the same
same thing like these are all probably
bigger problems in your research or your
your analysis then you know a small or
large p-value a newer thing so assuming
that you're happy with p-values or each
so you're not happy with p-values but
you've kind of checked off all the
potential problems a new thing that is
coming around is called s values and
it's the the base to log the negative
base to log of the p-value so why is
this preferable well at first it's not
used as a decision criteria we don't say
like oh the S value is less than
negative seven therefore we accept the
the alternative hypothesis it's not it's
more a measure of surprise or
information it's it's base to for a
reason
base to it can be used to think about
information and entropy logs are also
the right scale to think about
probabilities so the p-value is a
probability the the raw probabilities
are really hard for humans to interpret
and a good example of this is say P is
equal to 0.5 and I want to add point
zero one very small like increment to
0.5 it might only take me like two
tosses to sort of sorry it might take me
like thousands of tosses for me to
notice that difference that AI bias my
coin a little bit instead if I added Oh
point 0 1 to 0.98 it might take me like
three tosses in order to detect a
difference doesn't ouch it kind of
sucked I'm sorry the important thing is
that we're all probabilities are not
linear like money is or or like lengths
are probabilities are sort of stuck
between 0 and 1 and that completely
distorts how we how we look at them the
log is the the right way to look at
probabilities so this kind of like
linearizes the probability if we can
speak more meaningfully about like a
negative 7 versus a negative 5s value
whereas a negative earth so whereas a
point zero zero for p value how do you
compare that to point zero zero two
because it's not a difference of point
zero zero two in the same way in the
same way and finally like the analogy to
think about as well is a p-value of 0.05
is four point three bits of information
it's using like a coin flipping analogy
that's barely more surprise or
information than ninjas and then just
seeing about four heads comes up in a
coin flip like four heads coming up in a
coin flip isn't that impressive but
that's kind of what a p-value of 0.05
which is like the gold standard and what
everyone uses is saying so this this
talks this is like again a perception
issue the log is the right way to think
about probabilities and then there's
also this the trend of removing
asterisks from p-value table tables you
see a table that's very small I'm sorry
you see a table like this with these
asterisks beside the p-values or beside
like the the estimate to say like this
is how significant it is that's
inappropriate technically if you're
using a null hypothesis testing
framework the problem is is that p-value
is a bar sorry the significance is a
binary thing you can't say this is more
significant than something else so
whether it's point zero zero one or
point zero zero
I've kind of both significant it's also
moving the goalposts after the fact so
what you're saying by putting these
asterisks and you're saying like even if
we had chosen Oh point zero zero zero
one as our peers are sort of threshold
as our alpha value we still would have
you know confirmed this hypothesis so
you're kind of like moving the goalposts
after the experiments been done so using
asterisks and papers is not really the
right thing type 1 type 2 errors these
are always confusing to me and I don't
think the right way to think about these
problems
Gelman I mentioned him he introduces the
idea of type 2 type 2 new types of
errors the first is type s and this is
the what's the probability that you got
the sign wrong in your estimate and
that's really useful like you don't want
to get the sign wrong but you through
but you want some way to measure how
wrong you might be if you get the sign
wrong you might be giving a drug that is
harmful to the to the patient you might
be choosing a path for your business
that as you know negative consequences
so let's type s the probability of the
sign being wrong and then type M is the
magnitude which is also very important
how how off are you in the magnitude of
your point estimate so these are much
more interesting conceptual tools to
think about your your parameter rather
than like type 1 type 2 these are like
concrete kind of things that we can keep
you indicate and and understand better
confidence intervals have a very
complicated interpretation which I again
I don't want to get into the newer way
to look at confidence intervals is all
right here here's a here's a story I
guess so some researchers who were
looking at the negative effects or side
effects of a new anti-inflammatory drug
they noted that the risk ratio comput
intervals were point nine seven to one
point four eight technically because one
is inside that constant confidence
interval the null hypothesis can't be
rejected so they concluded that no harm
reduction or no no harm would come by
using this drug but that's very silly
it's like it's bare
one is barely in that interval if just
by chance the risk ratio is actually
1.48 you're causing harm to patients and
you know kind of likely it is gonna be
greater than one if I look at it this
way
yeah the p-value in this case was 0.09
one so they they didn't reject the null
but it's strange for them to not do
something about that that this is kind
of alarming I put up here if you're
blindly following this kind of p-value
decision criteria decision thresholding
you might you know miss this so what you
want to do instead is look at the most
extreme left hand side on the right hand
side of the interval and then interpret
what would happen in those extremes so
in that in that anti-inflammatory drug
case they would say either there's no
harm reduction like it 0.97 is pretty
close to one or they would say like oh
there's actually a valid concern that we
were actually harming patients by giving
them this this drug and that might spur
more research and more funding into
looking at this drug rather than just
saying like oh it's fine let it go so
you want look at the the point estimate
limits and technically all values in
that interval that confidence interval
are valid you can't say this is more
likely than this one technically but
that's that's a very useful
interpretation someone yesterday and one
of the talks I forget which talk now but
they said using the lower bound and
upper bound as like the extreme cases
for your business I got like that like
the best-case scenario worst-case
scenario I think that's a good way to
think of it too so there's the the
old-school thoughts around like the
testing framework of science where we
have null hypothesis tests and we want
to use like p-values and alpha alpha see
the vacants levels to sort of decide
what's true what's not true that has the
accept reject hypotheses the p-values as
this decision criteria type 1 and type 2
errors instead we want to move to this
estimation framework where we're looking
at estimates and CIS and interpreting
them we're not blindly following this
this rule
we're saying okay what's actually
happening like what's what's what can I
meaningfully meaningfully interpret in
this situation sort of abandoning null
hypothesis testing because there's too
many problems with that with p-value
hacking and whatnot and then thinking
about like type s type M errors these
are much easier in the Bayesian
framework than in frequentist framework
so going being a thing again about my
priority list try a Bayesian approach
first for your situation that if that
doesn't work try frequentist and if you
want to follow people on Twitter who I
think are great are talking along about
this and sort of proposing new ideas I
like these these folks they all have
like something entering too interesting
to say this prof Matt Fox he has a great
great podcast with some of his friends
called oh no it's us what is it called
Association something what is it yeah I
forget it I'll post it later
or but come to me but it's a great blog
post where they discuss a lot of these
problems as well and yeah follow these
people they'll learn a lot from them
real associations I'm blanking questions
comments thank you thanks again for
attending my tutorial I hope you learn
something and yeah take it back to your
co-workers and lab mates thank you
[Applause]
if you can if you can go busy like I
said like go go that way to interpret
things you know with with probabilities
and it's really nice I think
unfortunately a lot of people can't go
Bayesian for technology reasons for like
education reasons or the problems just
too complex or something so I would say
like nothing stopping that I guess I'm
offering an approach to the case we
can't do Bayesian z' but if you already
basin's you're absolutely right like the
posterior risk distribution is the right
way to do things
credible intervals are awesome and and
like easy to interpret so I would say
like you're right but if you can't do
that
do these yeah and unfortunately like may
not unfortunately I shouldn't start wars
but like people still do frequent to
stuff and that's fine majority of people
still do this other questions yeah
yep yep
sure tribute the question so what can
you interpret the s value more
for example the s value if the p value
is 1 the s value is 0 which makes sense
and then as p value gets closer to 0 how
does the s value change and what is the
interpretation you could interpret it as
like the the the coin flip analogy I
think I think is correct
so as the p value equals 0 you have more
and more coins that are landing heads
and you should be more surprised if
you've flipped 15 coins they're all
heads something's going on there but if
you flip like four coins and are all
heads it's like well that's just could
happen by chance not so important the
like some some P values like some
experiments are so well designed and
there's such a large effect size that
the p value is on the order of like 10
to the minus 6 or 7 or 8 or something
higher than that I think people's brain
kind of loses understanding after a few
exponents but in the S value case it's
like a linear system so you see an S
value of like 200 and that's easier to
interpret that an AP value of you know
10 to the minus 9 or 10 to the minus 10
or something so there's that value too
you can also like there's a there's an
additive argument like s values can add
together which you can't add P values
together so there's that piece too
yeah I think the information our
surprise approaches the right approach
any other questions about yep
yeah I would I don't have a pinion
tensorflow because I've never directly
used their auto diff functions I
so I mentioned Auto grad the maintainer
zuv autograph moved on to Google
actually they got hired by Google and
they're not working on this new package
called Jack's
J ax which is really cool it's supposed
to be kind of the replacement for
tensorflow one day probably not because
of so much momentum behind tensor flow
but it's it's again just an auto diff
library but it has like neural network
components to it and you don't have to
use the tensor flow API like the kind of
complicated data structures that they
provide with Jack's you can use just
numpy functions just like Auto grad like
technically Jax is a drop-in replacement
for auto grad I think it's overkill for
what I need and it also doesn't work
well on Windows yet so I'm sticking with
autograph for most of my purposes and
it's faster to and bet easier to debug
so that's my answer that I wouldn't use
tensor flipper Auto diff I would use
Jack's for auto diff yeah give him the
choice and I implemented like a really
simple neural network library using
Jack's and it was like so so simple to
do with Jack's and so Jack's is cool too
because it offers GPU support natively
just like tensorflow does but Jack's
code just reads a lot easier so yeah I
like Jack's
any other questions sure yeah I'll take
a question though if anything is
available you know go okay so quickly
where were we we were talking about oh
yeah so we added this weird thing to my
likelihood is I want to add information
to my likelihood that the variance of
every other parameter because I remember
my parameter is one describes in between
then the churn in between churn so the
variance of every other parameter I want
to be very small and that's kind of
described here I have this KP analyzer
term if you if you're familiar with like
P lasers in the regression
it's a peel answer term on the variance
I might owe my variance to be small for
both the in between periods and the
churn periods so this like I don't know
how to differentiate this I've never
seen a penalize err with this kind of
weird variance term in it usually you
see like the absolute or the the l2 norm
of parameters is small I'm doing
something with like variances that is a
function of the mean which is like a
function of the parameters it's kind of
complicated but this just chews through
it like let's just execute this and it
converges fine and we can see the
hazards note that there's no variance
between the heights of these as I should
make one point I put a very high
panelizer on here I'll change it in a
second I just want to show as a proof of
concept so there's no variances in these
heights there's no variance in these if
I quickly just change it to the survival
function we can see what it looks like
in the survival space I'll go back up
here and I'll sort of tone this down to
say ten to the eighth and go back to the
hazard it's easier to see okay this
little variant still too high let's try
six so we heard to see like a bit more
variance because I have less than
penalise rounding the variance in the
different terms the Bayesian
interpretation of this is
puling if you're familiar with like how
pooling works and bayesian world I have
like obvious I have like the the in
between parameters and the churn
parameters coming from a family of one
distribution kind of and I'm penalizing
the variance on that family so if this
is analogous to Bayesian pooling in an
MLE framework it's just nuts in my
opinion that you can just different you
just add these terms differentiate it
like I could put in again I can put them
anything I want squared
sure whatever the hell that means or the
square root I should that makes more
sense the standard deviation yeah I
didn't like that so much but you get the
idea
so you can do well things like that
that's the idea again the other kind of
thing I want to emphasize is like I'm
adding information about the model about
my prior prior knowledge about the model
and the data collection into my
likelihood that's like the source of
inference cool any questions
sure real quick
some of it comes from just prior
knowledge like if you know there's going
to be domain knowledge us right some of
they can also be done using the AIC or I
guess yeah AIC in this case the yeah
yeah the yeah the information criteria
you can use that to compare different
models together that just realized in
the likelihood and the number of
parameters which are I mean in this case
its hold on in this case this is the
likelihood value so you can do things
like that yeah okay that's that's all
for me I'll be around kind of the rest
of the day we can shop more if you want
yeah feel free to share this and thanks
again for coming and really appreciate
it